Hey, what's up everyone? So you
asked for it and you got it!
Today we're learning English with Frozen 2.
Now, we'll be looking at two
scenes from this incredible movie.
First off we will be learning with the
theme song and then after that we will
learn with a funny scene featuring
Anna and Olaf. Let's get into it!
Isn't that song great? Well now we are going to
learn all of the most difficult vocabulary and
pronunciation from it, but quickly before we do,
I want to let you know that, if you are new here,
every single week we make lessons
like this with your favorite songs,
movies, series and so much more. So that you
can understand fast speaking natives without
getting lost, without missing the jokes
and without subtitles. Just like Akirandu,
who says that they even cried the first time
that they understood without the subtitles
thanks to our videos. And you can too. It's
really simple: join over 3 Million learners
from around the world by hitting that
Subscribe button and the Bell down below.
Do you want to master native sound
morphing like this? Then don't miss
THIS lesson that we made on our
second channel RealLife English.
Now, if it's important for you to understand
natives even when we speak really fast and
morph our words like we've seen here, then I
highly recommend you try our 3-Part Masterclass.
Now, in this Masterclass you will be
learning English with the TV Series Friends,
which various academic studies show is one of
the best series out there for learning English.
And you will be learning the 3 Principles to
be able to understand natives at any speed. And
that is vocabulary, pronunciation and cultural
context. So what are you waiting for? The best
part of all this is that you can sign up right
now for FREE. All you have to do is click up here
or down description below to learn more.
Now I look forward to seeing you inside.
So many of my students tell me that they are
really frustrated by learning phrasal verbs.
There's just so many of them and how do you
remember all of them, right? Well if you want
to learn all about phrasal verbs and how you can
never forget them, then I highly recommend that
next you check out this lesson you'll find that
by clicking up here or down the description below.